[Music]
[Music]
hey
so we're back here if you're listening
to the audio you're like uh why isn't
anybody talking
because i'm making goofy ass faces
that's why yeah yeah it's
tuesday is it not yeah it's tuesday and
uh
this will actually be our last live
matinee of the week because
as i mentioned yesterday if you were not
here we decided we were gonna go
uh on wednesday evening and do like a
more
sidetracks kind of route i'll probably
just call it sidetracks and put it in
the side tracks
um playlist because i already have one
made for that okay
um so yeah we'll probably do that
tomorrow at 5 pm eastern
we'll have some drinks yeah because i
kind of feel guilty drinking at three
in the afternoon but i don't feel guilty
drinking at five in the afternoon i know
that's dumb
but uh yeah we'll get some music going
in the background and we won't have a
topic or anything we'll just
sit here and yap like we usually do but
we won't feel bad about going off on
tangents and stuff because it'll just
all be tangents we'll have a we'll have
a good soundtrack going in the back
it'll be fine yeah i gotta find some
[ __ ] yeah so yeah that'll be tomorrow
so uh interactive show this yeah well
and we'll do like we'll
we'll answer questions and all that kind
of [ __ ] it'll be it'll be super cool
this one interesting we were actually
looking on amazon prime
for uh you know a newer movie or when
they came out this year they
actually have one called come to daddy
which i've been wanting to see for a
while which i think is 2020 or 2019.
um and i will probably get around to
doing that one next week because i still
really want to see that movie
however while we were scrolling through
we saw this one now this is from 2014
but somehow even though it's a stephen
king adaptation
it just totally passed us by i had no
idea
that this story had even been adapted uh
this is stephen king's a good marriage
he didn't direct this one but he did
write the screenplay i guess it's based
on
um if you guys read that book it was
four novellas
called full dark no stars i think it
came out in 2010
and um this was one of the stories that
was in there i think i read it when it
first came out like a long time ago
because i did kind of remember this
story
so basically it's interesting because
this has gotten kind of shitty reviews i
think it has like 35 40 percent positive
reviews and lots of more negative
reviews
it's a yeah i mean compared to i mean
it's not
a masterpiece or anything like that but
it was it was completely watchable and
completely enjoyable
just you know like a thriller i think
what it is is that it wasn't really
off the wall sure it had been more off
the wall with like you know
gore or more like supernatural type [ __ ]
they probably would have liked it
the story is just like a regular stephen
king kind of
story but this is a lot more grounded in
reality
a woman finds out woman's in the damn
area where there's a serial killer she's
kind of worried about the serial killer
um turns out she finds out later that
that she knows the serial killer she's
married to him she's been
married to him for [ __ ] 30 years yeah
25 years because they're yeah they're
having a 25th anniversary party at the
beginning
yeah and he's kind of a kind of like a
btk
and he's kind of i think modeled after
the btk he is yeah stephen king said
that
yeah and uh you know [ __ ]
what's she gonna do you know and this is
what the story's about i mean he's not
so much modeled after btk
um i guess the way he kills them it is
but yeah the the idea that
um somebody like btk could have a wife
and kids in a regular life
um and they didn't know anything about
it and it went on for years and years
that's kind of more what he used as an
inspiration for this
it's like what if what if you found out
your husband was btk
yeah that's the story yeah i thought it
was good uh it wasn't real gross
didn't have a lot of gore and it was
more like a cycle more like a like
like a psychological drama wouldn't you
say yeah psycho thriller
and not a lot of i mean it's it's not
like there was a lot of mystery to it or
anything because you find out like
pretty
early early that her husband is
bt that's what he's called yeah there's
more to it than that though you know
there's all these family
ties and family [ __ ] loyalties and
[ __ ]
it's just you know it's it's
not it's not like say
you're not talking maximum overdrive you
know bad or anything
okay although that's still pretty
entertaining yeah
but and you're not really talking about
the shining it's not that tone
it's just yeah the shining or misery or
shawshank redemption
yeah yeah yeah this is a middle
level one something about it kind of
reminded me of uh
uh what was it what was that story that
he had thinner there's something about
it just kind of reminded me of thinner i
don't know maybe because
i kind of have i kind of have a soft
spot for the film adaptation of thinner
yeah
it's not good but i don't know well
there's something about the story of
thinner where
you know some [ __ ] it's out in the open
and you're dealing with it for a long
period of time you don't know what's
gonna happen he's getting thinner and
there and he's trying to solve it
well she you know for a long time that
he's a serial killer
in its situation getting worse and worse
and how she gonna solve it
so for some reason it it kind of
reminded me of that but
you know i might have been yeah no i get
what you're saying kind of like the
tempo of the story
yeah it's more like like i said there's
not any mystery to it because you know
that you figure out like in the first 15
minutes that he's a serial killer like
she figures it out because she finds um
one of the victims like she's seen it on
the news and she finds one of the
victim's
ids like hidden like in his garage his
little man cave or whatever
so she finds out about it and then when
she she kind of pretends like she
doesn't know but she's super upset
and then he just comes clean and he's
like yeah you know it's like me and this
kid that i grew up with
who he got the name from um yeah he gave
me the idea to be a serial killer kind
of this i mean this is
pretty much if you read the story it's
almost
exactly like the story i mean which
isn't surprising because stephen king
adapted it
he wrote the screenplay from his own
novella i think the only major thing
that's different
is that in the story when he talks about
his past and this friend
um that they that they were gonna do
serial killer [ __ ] together where he got
the serial killer idea from or whatever
um i think in this story they were going
to do like a school shooter thing like
the pull of columbine um but in the
movie
i think he basically says something like
they were these girls were
snoots i think they called them and so
they were going to like teach them a
lesson sort of like i'm going to rape
and kill him
so which makes more sense with the [ __ ]
that with the crimes that he committed
later on because they were
btk like you know what i mean because he
had because she even finds like a bdsm
magazine and his stuff too right like
right before
she finds the idea because she's like oh
okay i didn't know he was into this [ __ ]
but um yeah so joan allen is in this she
plays the wife
darcy anthony lapalia uh plays
bob bob the serial killer it's weird
because when i first saw him i was like
i thought it was gabriel byrne i'm like
god damn he looks so much like gabriel
byrne these days
um also i like stephen lang was in this
he
played like the detective yeah he wasn't
in it enough though
he was so good he was so good in vfw
yeah you didn't really know much about
that
character until later on yeah he was
just kind of lurking around like
you know creeping on people
it was a good movie it wasn't one of the
greatest but there was nothing bad about
it
you know yeah it didn't have bad acting
it didn't have bad edit or anything it
was just a
decent decent it was perfectly
serviceable yeah and i had a good time
too because
as i said i think and we probably talked
about this on our btk show too
we should have got btk over here for
this
come on dennis what do you what do you
think about this movie
but um but yeah so yeah well yeah
it was okay they made a movie about me
best one was silver bullet
[Laughter]
because it has gary busey being crazy in
it i love silver bullet
we should actually do we should do a
review on silver bullet one of these
days i think they have that one
is one btk would like yeah that seems
like something he would like he wouldn't
like dead zone
no no you go again he's like
he's trying to figure out what stephen
king adaptations beating
the best he likes like children of the
corn
[Laughter]
yeah i can see that yeah he would
totally relate to the kids
yeah but i think that that happens you
know
whole towns i'm from
i'm from kansas i got the x factor
x factor living underneath the town cops
try to stop it doesn't have it doesn't
help
kids all understand it yeah they're all
minotaurs yeah like minotaurs
it turns them into minotaurs little
pants and pants and seders
but yeah so i think that you need to
down to church more
yeah i guess so but that that's the
thing it brings up the moral dilemma
because this is one thing that always
fascinated me about btk and i think it
fascinates a lot of people
how serial killers who we just
i i guess not so much nowadays but you
kind of picture them as like these
drooling ogres or whatever
and it's really weird to us to think
that somebody that you're married to for
25 years and have grown kids with and
you know think is a normal person and
then suddenly you find out they're a
serial killer
and it's like how how does that affect
you like
what you know what i mean and i'm saying
like i'm watching this movie
and i guess because it's me like as soon
as she
found out that he was a serial killer i
don't think i would have like pretended
that i didn't know i would have just
waited for him i would have just been
like yeah cool whatever and then like as
soon as he came home i just would have
like smothered her death or something
like that
but well i mean she does eventually
spoiler alert she does eventually end up
killing him and making it look like an
accident because that's what i said i
said kill me make it look like an
accident so that's what she did she was
listening to me
but um but seriously the whole time it's
like i don't understand
i i get why she didn't want to tell
anybody like she didn't want to turn him
in
because she was like well she didn't
want the kids to know
i guess right because it wasn't like one
of their daughters because their kids
were grown they had two and one of their
daughters was getting married
and she found out like a week before the
daughter was getting married and so she
was just kind of like well i don't want
the daughter
you know the kids finding out that their
dad is a serial killer
which i don't know man i i don't know if
i would have
i don't know i don't have kids so i i
don't really know how you would feel in
that situation but i feel like that's a
given don't
i imagine a lot of [ __ ] serial
killers that never got caught maybe went
down this way maybe somebody in their
family found out about him and killed
him
[ __ ] that's possible i mean you can't
blame them remember how remember how we
were
i was doing the thing on um on the
original nightstalker
yeah and i called it i said that dude's
a cop
yeah i also thought that maybe somebody
got him i thought so too got somebody i
thought he broke into somebody's house
and somebody
[ __ ] got the drop on him and then
made a stew out of his ass
yeah but you know i betcha too bad that
didn't i wonder if that [ __ ]
and then all of a sudden you got caught
yeah was about a year later
yeah i wonder if that [ __ ] heard that
show heard our show
see i always wonder every time we do
shows about serial killers that are
still alive
if they have access to i don't know if
they
i don't know if they let them watch i
don't think that i don't know
they might have phones but uh no it
makes you wonder uh
if uh original nightstalker what was his
name again um
uh d'angelo d'angelo i don't know i bet
you dean angelo didn't even have youtube
yeah he seemed like just this grouchy
little man he pretty fast
you probably didn't even use computers
that you didn't even know how computers
work
all that garbage on the internet it's
all just yeah he definitely seems like
that type of dude my dad's like that
yeah i had to stand straight on that
remember that when he was over here
oh that internet [ __ ] yeah there's
nothing on that
he still thought it was he still thought
he was jumping on there
he still thought he was uh like in 1996
or something
when there actually was nothing good
[Laughter]
that's pretty funny but yeah so so i you
know i had a good time with this
yes i had had a drink or two yeah
um so the whole time i was just kind of
like i was giving her tips
you know because because i told him i
was like this is why this is why [ __ ]
love true crime [ __ ] because
you never know when you're gonna need
that stuff so i was like telling her
what to do i'm like you got to make it
look like an accident you got to like
you know bleach the sink out and then
you got to do this on the other side so
i was telling this [ __ ] ain't that
something
you're not a serial killer i know that
but you know she's always i'd kill that
[ __ ]
[ __ ] to sleep talking i'm just
like stab him in the face and run just
look at the face yeah and i'm
looking over going damn i better [ __ ]
stay on my [ __ ] p's and q's
you better because if i dude if i found
out you were a serial killer
like if i was because we've been
together well like almost 10 years and i
was just like if i found out you were a
serious kid i wouldn't even hesitate
i'm telling you that right now yeah you
know what if there's something else so
you might as well you know what if it
was
i don't know what was it like what i
mean serial killer is pretty much
pretty much the worst thing i've heard
you say some crazy [ __ ] about dudes i'd
cut his dick off
just weird [ __ ] [ __ ] like that you're
not well you know
and that's what i saw hey don't [ __ ]
with us that's all i'm saying i'd cut
that motherfucker's balls off we'll see
well yeah yeah i would too well the
thing about it is that
the thing about it
[Laughter]
duct tape
you totally need a [ __ ] a [ __ ]
iron what what the hell is those things
called
[ __ ] dude thank you i could i couldn't
think of [ __ ]
cassidy lock it all up like make a [ __ ]
mad she
don't know she's mad at you and then you
wake up and she lorena boppets your ass
well that's what i mean well that's what
i said to this woman because she's i'm
just like
one it's the fact that she'll she kind
of pretended to go along
like oh yeah i won't turn you in like
you just you have to promise like pinky
swear you're not going to do it again
but i think she was like after the
wedding and everything
she was going to kill his ass anyway i
think she was just kind of like because
i'm sitting there going
how can you not i mean you know where
the [ __ ] sleeps um you know he's right
there
it's like even if you don't want to make
a mess i'm like just [ __ ] smother his
ass he's right there he's got to sleep
sometime
so you know but i'm i'm glad that she
like you know woman up and
did that [ __ ] she overeat up she dropped
his hits and dropped
she dropped her tits yeah
and like i said did it a really smart
way to make it make it look like an
accident so then that way
even if they found out later that he was
a serial killer she'd probably still get
in trouble but if you you know make it
look like an accident then it's just
like oh
how tragic and then like his kids were
all sad and [ __ ] she was just like man
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
yeah see now that you spoiled the movie
[Laughter]
well i feel like one the movie is
six years old and the story
is like 10 years old 11 years old
so i kind of feel and like i said it's
not like it's a big huge surprise you
kind of know how it's going to go like
as soon as you
figure out because the re i mean the
fact that it's called
a good marriage the fact that you know
from the poster
that it has like a mr and mrs towel and
then the mr one has blood all over it
like a handprint
so it's like you pretty much know that
oh her husband's a serial killer and how
the [ __ ] is she gonna deal with
that so i mean there's really only one
or two ways it could go right
i mean she could kill his ass he could
kill her ass it could go you know what i
mean
so there's only a couple ways it could
go so it's not like i don't feel that
bad about spoiling it like i said
because it's old anyway
but uh yeah so it's a decent movie it's
not amazon prime
if you're kind of in the mood for a
stephen king type of yeah i saw it for
free on amazon
thriller yeah and like i said there's a
couple other ones because i because
there was a couple newer ones i wanted
to watch too but we just saw that one
and i was like oh
stephen king adaptation that i didn't i
mean it's not as good as the ones they
had on netflix like gerald's game in
1922 and [ __ ] like those were like
really good this one was
fun it was fine yeah you know it's fun
all right so uh this one's i mean we've
been going on for 21 minutes
but uh yeah so you guys like i said
we're gonna do an unscripted live stream
i guess we're gonna just start doing it
every wednesday now
it'll be like a regular show but in the
middle of the week and it won't have a
topic we'll just be on here you can ask
questions we'll have music we'll drink
we'll dick around with you guys
yeah it'll be super fun we can talk
about whatever we want to talk
about and i won't be over there gonna be
a talk show
you know what i mean well maybe i will
but not for this not for the reasons i
usually
all right so we will see you guys
tomorrow evening
at 5 00 p.m for our fun show
and uh that'll do it so thanks for
dropping by we'll see you tomorrow
bye man you can't even wait
he's like i'm leaving